David pilling welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much for having me I'm
Constance and kisum and this is the show
for you if you were bored of people
arguing on the internet about subjects
they know nothing about trigonometry we
don't pretend to be the experts we ask
the experts here at the world-famous
angel comedy club our amazing expert
guests this week is David pilling who is
the Africa editor for the Financial
Times and the author of the growth
delusion
David pilling welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much for having me it is
a bit of a weird studio we have here's
like a black curtain and pretty much
nothing else it could be an Isis video
that's pretty much where we are
so David welcome to the show thank you
very much for coming on we really look
forward to speaking to you about your
book the growth delusion but before we
do that tell us a little bit about how
you are where you are and have maybe
you've formed the opinions that you have
now how's that house okay I mean look
I've been a journalist at the Financial
Times for longer than I'd care to
mentioned but you know 25 years let's
say and throughout that time I've been
posted abroad I was posted in Latin
America I was in Japan then I covered
all of Asia now I cover Africa and I've
covered many other things in between and
one of the things that struck me or
crept up on me is that we use this term
GDP gross domestic product which really
is synonymous with via economy when we
talk about the economy or when we talk
about growth that is what we're talking
about GDP and as a journalist working
for the Financial Times are very serious
and I think actually an excellent
newspaper but one becomes used to using
that as a kind of a metric and you
measure things against it tax to GDP
debt to GDP you know and this economy is
growing by 3% so it must be better than
this one that's only growing at two and
not nearly as good as that one that's
growing at ten but it's it began to
creep up on me well what does this
number really mean what's in it and when
I'm turn to Japan
I moved to Japan in 2008 2001 and Japan
was supposedly an example of an economy
that was in utter crisis it had
stagnated for 10 years and was to
stagnate for another ten practically
while I was there
its GDP in nominal terms just did not
move at all if it was a heart patient
Japan was dead and that is how that is
how people at the FT used to kind of a
you know when people talked about Japan
they'd talk in these kind of mournful
sort of sort of sorrowful voices like
what happened there then you know why is
it in such a mess and and so I began to
kind of think well this is not
reflecting the reality that I'm seeing
around me which was a society with lots
of problems for sure but incredibly
dynamic looked Tokyo certainly looks to
me far richer than London in many ways
quality of life was far better
I thought than in Britain and it
certainly was not a society anyway they
designated it was changing it was moving
it was adapting maybe not always in the
right ways but GDP didn't seem to be
telling me anything at all that was
really worth knowing about Japan and a
politician came from London I was taking
him through the streets of Tokyo which
you know can be kind of overall really
in this sort of you know what the stuff
that's going on and the lights and the
people lining up for incredible
restaurants and all this activity and he
said David if this is a recession I want
one so basically I mean I could go on
but but basically I began to think well
what is this number that we take so
seriously and yet you know I have found
just in my reporting that it doesn't
always tell you sometimes tells you but
it doesn't always tell you everything
you need to know at all and so what what
is in this number and why have we come
to take it so seriously so that's the
genesis of my book so if you were gonna
explain GDP to an absolute layman who's
never encountered it how would you
describe it
okay well GDP was invented in the 1930s
so it's man-made as we treated now
probably treats it now you know you
could say height you could say meters
and feet a man-made but you're measuring
something real GDP is measuring a kind
of
an artificial construct I would say
first of all so it measures all the
goods and services produced in a year
and at market prices at the it assigns a
price to that so there's a rationality
to it and but it's a measure of what
economists call flow it only measures
income and it measures what you're
producing in a particular period and
actually a period that's already gone in
the past it doesn't tell you really that
much about what might come in the future
and for example if you were looking at a
company if you were investing in a
company you wouldn't just look at its
profits because maybe its profits were
brilliant last year but maybe it had
sold off all its intellectual property
fired all its workers you know sold off
all its machinery and next year you knew
it's going to make zero but a someone
investing in the company would never
settle for that they'd say what's your
balance sheet look like what are your
assets and we don't do that
within a within economy we only look at
the flow now there's much much much more
that I can tell you about GDP but that's
that's you're sort of starting
definition well that's really
interesting but and so I read a few
interviews reviewed which were
absolutely fascinating particular one
with the Washington Post and you were
talking about things like theft being
part of GDP
well theft can be part of GDP GDP is
meant to measure and it varies from
country to country which is important
there's the sort of standardized measure
but it doesn't mean that it's an exact
science and when we talk about Britain's
GDP in the US GDP and America's GDP
sorry America is America Latino exactly
okay so they're not entirely comparable
but they are more or less anyway and
theft generally counts if I steal your
Porsche you have one I believe
anyway if I steal your Porsche that does
not contribute to GDP however if I then
sell your paws on to you and then go out
and spend all my ill-gotten gains on
something then I have absolutely
contributed to GDP because GDP is
actually a measure another way of
looking at it it's kind of velocity it's
the it's the way that money moves
through the system and if I sell you
heroin that absolutely counts as GDP
because Britain counts hard drugs and
prostitution so we count heroin and feta
means cocaine crack cocaine ecstasy and
marijuana so if you don't take one of
those Frances then you're really not
doing your bit for so what I mean we're
laughing at it but one of the points you
make in the book and elsewhere is that
this way of looking at GDP actually has
serious consequence of a a quite
entertaining but it is absolutely it's
meant to tell you it's meant to be a
window or a door or what a trap door or
whatever you want to call it into this
what appears to be an arcane subject the
the economy economics GDP GDP went up
2.1 percent you know but blah blah blah
and and we kind of glaze over but a lot
of people glaze over and yet and if you
look at political manifestos and they
always talk about the economy this is
quite new actually until 1950 and the
economy and making the economy better
and all of that was not mentioned in
political manifestos I think in the last
Tory Party minute manifesto has
mentioned about 8 C times we will not do
anything bad to the economy we must make
policies that are good for the economy
so I feel that it is kind of incumbent
on us to know what it is we're talking
about when we're talking about the
economy and the way the single way we
measure our national economies well this
the the way that's that that certainly
is used in the sort of public discourse
is this weird
number GDP so I think that we ought to
know more about it I mean just to finish
off that story brexit so just before the
BRICS it vote there was a guy and a men
and went up from University College
London he went to Newcastle and he said
look we cannot vote for bricks like this
would be nuts and you know economists
tell us this will be very damaging for
our GDP and someone stood up in the
audience and said that's your bloody GDP
that's not our GDP so this is something
that's absolutely relevant to us and
just to finish finish finish Nicholas
Sarkozy and former French president who
commissioned the whole study into how we
measure our well-being in our lives and
he wrote a preface which was
extraordinarily good actually and he
said look when people look at their
lives as measured by experts and they're
told that their lives look a certain way
but it just doesn't feel like that then
they become angry and he said and if
there's that gap nothing is more
dangerous to democracy and I think
that's quite prescient in an age of
Duterte and Trump and brexit and all
sorts of other things I'm not saying
that's the entire explanation but I am
saying that seems to touch a certain
nerve of the world we're living in today
well let's delve into that a little bit
but actually back back to your point
about the the Jordy guy I lived in
Scotland just before the referendum that
happened there and one of the points
that my Scottish friends were always
making to me after I left in this
discussion about the Scottish
independence movement they were always
saying well the London elites are
telling us that the economy's gonna be
better if we stay together and what my
Scottish friend says that's like saying
that someone else should sleep with my
wife because he'd be better at and I
think this idea that the economy is so
overwhelming thing that matters to
everybody I don't think people actually
find that that is their personal
experience but it used to be it's the
economy stupid that's what Bill Clinton
said and there may have been a time when
it was true I think it's not true now I
think people think about other things
and they also think that our definition
of the economy doesn't doesn't match our
lives isn't that it because for example
in the time of the economy stupid what
they were really talking about it's jobs
it's job security and these are things
that are a road
now and it's a [ __ ] and it may be
things like that are more intangible
than that like sense of community or
safety things that for example were very
strong in Japan that weren't being
picked up at all or you know I mean look
as services are about 80% of our
economies but GDP is absolutely awful at
measuring services very good at
measuring tables and chairs and mugs and
things you can drop on your foot or put
in a wheelbarrow
but it's dreadful at measuring haircuts
and psychoanalysis sessions and
investment banking products and you know
Boeing engine service contracts and
computer contracts and all the things
that are actually part of our modern
life GDP is very very bad because it
can't really figure out quality so we're
using a measure of quantity I would
argue to measure what is increasingly a
life that's defined by quality and the
other just sort of elephant in the room
sorry tea is that horrible cliche but
it's distribution then so you're talking
about Scotland so when we talk about the
economy is doing well the economy is
growing by two percent that doesn't tell
you anything about how that money is
being distributed so the American
economy has been doing quite well with a
few dips for a long long time but it's
not doing quite well if you're a non
college graduate mmm and and even there
are some numbers that suggest that
median household wages have stagnated
since the 1970s so in fact the the
economy growing is kind of bad for you
because all you're doing is seeing other
people doing better and you being left
behind and that creates a huge anger or
certainly can create a huge anger and
there's a time when that tips from the
American Dream I too can make it too
no I can't this has been going on too
long the system's rigged against me so
you'll keep telling me that things are
good and things are getting better and
we're growing and with two times richer
and three times it's and four times
which should then we have been well it
bloody well doesn't feel like it to me
hmm so I mean again to use another
question to another cliche the million
dollar question is how do we redress
that balance where you know it seems to
be the rich are getting richer and
people going hey you know what the
economy is getting better then you'll go
and get my wages haven't increased so
what do we do well that there are
there are two questions wrapped up in
one there you know one is how would we
know so my book is principally a book
about in a sense measurement that makes
it sound boring but I think all these
issues kind of stem stem from that so I
mean my but but that is kind of the the
orbit of my book there are then policy
description prescriptions you know how
might you address this once you know
it's actually happened and you know what
I would say in my book is that we
shouldn't make GDP by growing the entire
economy the be-all and end-all we could
look at median household income which is
something that I just mentioned it's
just funny sorry David for anyone who's
not familiar with statistics can you
explain the difference between mean and
median okay yeah it's quite it's a bit
tricky so mean is you would you would
just you would add everything up and
divide by the number of people so if you
had so you know there's an economist
joke being an economist joke
unfortunately ladies and gentlemen it's
not very fun
Bill Gates walks into a bar on average
everyone in the room is a billionaire
that's the mean you didn't laugh that's
the mean you divide the room of a
hundred people by Bill Gates fortune and
everyone is a billionaire you know if
you have four people and they have an
average income of 25 that's not bad so
long as one person doesn't have a
hundred in which case the your other
three have unfortunately starved to
death and that's your mean yeah and
median is slightly different median you
line everybody up which I know sounds
slightly you line everybody up and you
pick the middle person and so then it's
not skewed by the fact that you've got
Bill Gates at this end and a few Bill
Gates is kind of who have distorted the
average and distorted what you might
think is a typical existence because the
typical in a very sort of economically
skewed Society is likely to be worse
than the average
would would suggest so so that's what
median is and that's why it's better
than say mean so the marion is like the
most representative of the middle ground
not
nothing's perfect yes and of course you
might have a lot of very poor people who
are just kind of left out of that but
yes it's the middle ground and so if you
if you shifted your number and so that
people stood up and didn't say I'm gonna
grow the economy by 3% which Donald
Trump said but if you said I'm going to
grow median household income sketchy by
3% then that could that would skew your
whole policy agenda now how you would
get there is to be debated
you know redistribution you know
subsidies training you know we could we
can discuss the details and that's
politics although one of the things I am
arguing in my book I see is that numbers
are politics you know they're not just
dry because what we choose to measure
actually sets our priorities for what we
then try to create and sometimes that
will be explicit and sometimes it will
be implicit we won't even notice that
we've set this agenda without really
knowing it and so my starting point
would be it's a slightly downgrade GDP
it's not a useless number at all it's a
they called it the great invention of
the 20th century and that's not entirely
unkind it's not entirely untrue I mean
and but you could downgrade it slightly
not don't take it as seriously as we do
and elevate a few other numbers numbers
that might tell us about distribution
numbers that might tell us about
sustainability the wealth what we're
doing to a natural environment what
we're doing to our infrastructure so the
details of that so median household
income is number one well what else
would you want to incorporate anything
you should have a proxy of
sustainability you know look Saudi
Arabia could be and in fact is you know
busily selling its oil creates a very
high standard of living GDP is going
fantastically well but what happens when
they all runs out GDP our standard
measure of the economy tells you zero
about that
that doesn't mean Saudi Arabia's are
stupid and they're not going to do
anything about it in fact they have a
whole political turmoil now part of
which may be that that's exactly what
they're trying to do they're trying to
do and something about it but some kind
of measure of sustained
ability and there are measures some of
them are very technical and we can talk
about those the World Bank has just come
out with one which I think is really
interesting but you could also come up
with a proxy and some of these things
are just proxies you could say co2 for
example it wouldn't be perfect but you
could say you know let's have a policy
you know let's run a society where the
aim is not merely to produce as much as
we can and you know hang the environment
you could have a policy that said co2 or
some other proxy of how sustainable this
growth is which was kind of set a limit
or would or would push you in different
directions so that if you wanted to grow
and we can discuss what grow might mean
you could grow in ways that don't
necessarily mean chucking tons of
plastic into the oceans for example
which has been a preferred method you
know hitherto yeah or you know you know
burning the ozone off or destroying all
our rainforests or heating up the earth
to such an extent that you know it is
already almost indubitably and and
certainly we'll even more as we go
forward you know change weather patterns
in ways that are highly unpredictable
and that could be and are likely to be
extremely damaging to lots of people
right absolutely first thing if we could
just go back so you were talking about
some of that that gap we were talking
about the gap between rich and poor how
much do you think I mean because I think
that's to make one of the major reasons
why Trump got to power is because no
politician addressed those people how
much do you think capital catalyst is to
blame how much is globalization to blame
and what can we do is essentially to try
and fix it really because it just seems
that things are getting harder and
harder yeah well there's a lot going on
so you know that one of the themes of
our age is that we're becoming more and
more unequal and so a lot of people
would knock their heads in that are we
listening to your globally not tell the
facts of ever so globally not so what is
what is happening is that especially in
wealthy countries that tends to be true
if you look at you know the top 10%
versus the bottom 10% you
to see this rising the differential
rising and in some cases rising quite
dramatically
I mean I've noticed that there are
numbers in Britain that seems to dispute
some of that but but you know as numbers
that I've looked at would show the
inequality has risen quite substantially
it may have tailed off at certain points
but it's risen quite substantially over
the last 20-30 years
in the u.s. it's risen an awful lot even
in egalitarian Japan it rose it's risen
in egalitarian Scandinavia so if you're
in the top percent college-educated do
computer science or whatever you know
you your global your international
you've got skills you're doing really
well now and if you're not you're sort
of falling behind however there is
another story and it's an important
story that gets kind of lost when our
debate which is the whole other parts of
the world China being a very you know a
prime example are actually beginning to
close that gap so if you look at the
differential between you know Chinese
income and US or British income you know
they've been closing that gap since the
1990s and you know at increasing kind of
speed I used to know these numbers off
by heart but you know let's say in 1990
the differential was about 20 it might
be about for now I mean this is like a
freight train coming so in that sense in
equality is not increasing globally and
globalization has actually been good but
it's been good if you're Chinese yeah
and it's been good if you're Indian now
on a globalist so to me that is great
because I think that you know China and
India but been exploited chops about by
colonialism pushed out of the global
system and you know they're now having
managed to incorporate themselves in and
it's it's you know it's not perfect by
any means I mean it's you know you know
politically or economically or in terms
of social justice you know but the
tendency is definitely that those
countries are catching up but it does
create all sorts of upheavals in our own
countries and we need to you know you
don't necessarily need to ditch
globalization to deal with that although
you might you might do at some point but
you don't have to but what you what you
do need to do is
have policies that smooth that ride and
which you know may well involve you know
training technology distribution
universal basic income higher
inheritance tax to make things fairer
when people die they just kind of pass
on privilege in a kind of Piketty style
fashion and you know to the next
generation and so combination of all
those but it would need to be a much
more kind of rigorous policy if you
really think that that's important I
mean I personally do think that's
important because some people don't some
people think inequalities you know even
in a place like America or Britain
some people argue it's good I disagree
with this entirely they say it's
motivational you know and why why do you
disagree with it and because I think
that that people are often wealthy by
fortune a fortune of birth fortune of
the school they went to fortune of their
connections there's a lot of luck they
may have trampled over a lots of people
on their way to get wealthy that if we
just say you know he's ten times
wealthier than I so he must be ten times
better I you know I absolutely reject
that and so I don't like this idea of a
meritocracy but one of the things you
talk about is that inequality is bad for
society well yeah I don't talk about
that much there are all books about this
but I absolutely think it it is I mean
look I used to be an idealist I'm
probably less of an idealist than it
used to be but you know so I think so
many quality is inevitable because you
know we could distribute the same amount
of money to the four of us and you know
probably you'd end up really wealthy and
he and I had end up on the street you'd
have to sell your Porsche you know no
matter how much you try you know you
could you you know but what I am
interested in is the equality of
opportunity look there are whole studies
and there's a whole chapter on happiness
and happiness I think has been in my
book I should say the happiness I think
has been a little bit sort of undermined
and ridiculed in a sense by this whole
Bhutanese you know Gross National
Happiness and where Bhutan put forward
happiness instead of GDP or economic
expansion and while it may have been on
something I think it's a sort of fairly
flawed exercise again we could talk
about that and if you'd like but looking
at this more rigorously I actually found
that when you measure happiness
economists call it subjective well-being
because it sounds posher and you might
take it more seriously it will be better
still but and look so a lot of
subjective well-being tests and you know
studies which show more or less the
following that if you're very poor
you're unhappy and you know if you can't
send your kids to school if you can't
put a roof over your head if you if you
worry about where the next meal is
coming from or you're what happens if
you get sick you will be unhappy you and
you will tell someone honor they call it
the cancel ladder scale you will tell
someone I'm really feeling unhappy now
once you begin to satisfy and those what
you might call basic needs human rights
whatever you want to call them and you
get to a certain level of wealth
now we could or income we could argue
about what that is let's say it's
$15,000 per capita or $20,000 per capita
what the studies find is that you
actually don't move much up so no money
after that more money like that doesn't
make much doesn't increase will be you
know streets I've got your 15 grand a
year
you're okay yes yes no that's what the
studies would suggest now think of it in
a different way let me tell you to kind
of anecdotes that might sort of bring
this to life so and if you're in a
football match and you're all sat down
and then one guy stands up craning his
neck and then someone else behind him
stands up and then someone else stands
up and before you know it the whole
stadium is stood up now they have
exactly the same view of the match that
they had before but they now all have
the inconvenience of having stood up a
bit of hat and having to stand up
through the whole match and that you
could argue is the group is the kind of
rat race cycle that we've kind of got
ourselves into we're all stood up you
know next will have to be on tippy toes
just to get you
even better and then maybe get a
stepladder so that and none of us are
gonna get a better view of the match
none of us are gonna have better
subjective well-being or feel more happy
in fact we'll for the less happy because
we're having to work harder for exactly
the same view of the match now different
what different and analogy there's a
great experiment where they put two
Capucine monkeys and if you haven't
looked it up look it up on YouTube I
think I've seen this so there's two
monkeys kind of everyone's seen it now
in these perspectives and they're being
there perform a simple task they hand
over little pebbles and in return for a
pebble they get given a cucumber and
they're both happy as Larry or happy as
capuchin monkeys or happy as people
we're watching a good football match or
whatever and then one of the trainer's
starts giving one of the monkeys grapes
which are better they're sweeter tastier
and the other monkey immediately but
immediately gets I right it's not
stretching the cage it flings the
cucumber back at thee and it will not
accept these cucumbers and it is unhappy
now because of relative reasons the
experiment is called monkeys rejects
unequal pay make a joke and it falls
flat that's what you do say that was
meant to be so that's a little bit about
their kind of the happiness quandary so
and I I remember watching a TED talk I
think and reading some some stuff by a
Swedish researcher who was talking about
the fact that when you take pretty much
every measure of subjective well-being
you're learning yeah quickly and you
plot that against income inequality
within a developed country like Britain
like America like Western what you find
is essentially every measure of
ill-being
yes goes up as inequality goes up so
people there's more teenage pregnancy
there's more people in prison there's
more violence there's more crime there's
more there's more everything it's
something cool there's a book all the
spirit level there's been a few other
books then absolutely tend to suggest
this and you can
it can't you I mean you know you could
be living perfectly content the guy next
door gets Porsche I'll keep going back
to your Porsche yeah you know now I want
a Porsche and you and it's sort of you
know you kind of hate yourself for it
but you sort of want it and you sort of
can feel this creep up on you and that I
would suggest I mean that's the sort of
depressing bit of my book in a sense
because although I kind of saved growth
is a delusion and we kind of need to
wake up cut it is something that tells
me that that there's something in all of
us me included that's just not going to
that there is this competitive need to
stay ahead and because look if you go to
a beach in the Bahamas or whatever and
nobody on that Beach is going to come
and serve you cocktails because they're
all played twice what you get paid
you're not going to like that Beach you
know you to some extent your experiences
are enjoyable because of the exclusivity
of those experiences so it's almost
built-in you know if you go to a
restaurant and the chef says we'll solve
this I'm not cooking for you you know
give me a thousand pounds or maybe I'll
cook you a meal
yeah you know you know your enjoyment of
a restaurant meal is that someone's
prepared to work for 20 20 quid an hour
or whatever it is and so there is this
kind of thing that's built into humanity
maybe depressingly that means that we're
on this kind of hamster wheel you know
it's very interesting number one if
anybody from Porsche is are you saying
that capitalism makes us miserable
possibly aspects of it I mean look what
you'd have to define capitalism on you
the acquirement of material I mean I
don't think socialism or communism made
as much so you know that's a term so I'd
be a bit uncomfortable with that issue
of material gold Sonny can
you know but I mean my mind isn't a
self-help book it's not a you know I
mean look if you want to live in an
empty room and live on experiences
I mean look that but but I think despite
our kind of you know some collecting
society and we are sort of almost
there's certainly a sub trend of that if
you think what people collect now
actually I mean it's not very healthy in
some senses but they collect experiences
that they can project you know onto
social media that's it's kind of
ethereal or they or they collect music
the experience of music but it just has
to be streamed you don't need a record
collection
so you know even in this on a cluttered
technological heavy materialistic world
we live in you can kind of see something
fighting to come out and yeah I mean no
I didn't used to not carry a camera
around for 20 odd years I've traveled
all over the world and I remember one
time I was hitching through Africa as a
19 year old and I had a sort of crappy
little camera but the camera was
everything to me because I wanted to
capture these experiences and so you
know I don't know why is hard to analyze
yourself but so I could show people
impress people I didn't so I could
remember I'm not quite sure but I do
remember thinking like preserving this
camera keeping this camera and keeping
these rolls of film is like so important
to me to such an extent that it could
even get in the way of your experience
of what you're actually experience at
the time so at that after that I took
this kind of zen-like attitude really
until the you know modern mobile phones
of never carrying a camera so I'd go to
tons of places and I'd see you know to
my mind astonishing things in the
natural world and the you know in the
human world in the physical world and I
would look at them and kind of try to
commit them to memory and look at them
unfiltered not through a lens you could
say that's kind of Zen you could say
there's anti collecting things but I was
collecting stuff I was collecting memory
no in the end it's all gonna go you know
you can collect a Porsche it's gone when
you die or when it's stolen or when
someone rams into it you can collect
memories and they're gone when you die
or if you you know your memory begins to
go and if you get Alzheimer's or
whatever so everything is ethereal but
my book is not
[Laughter]
great what on the subject of happiness
is there a way you think that for I
remember you talked about the time but
actually David Cameron I think in 2015
he proposed this measure of the public
happiness or whatever it was called
he was broadly ridiculed by everybody he
was yeah it's easy to really kind of I
know I was quite surprised by that
because I've always saw actually you
know happiness is quite an important
measure of what's happening in society
and I just finished reading sapiens by
an Israeli historian whose name I can
neither you bel know her re thank you
perfect and one of the things he talks
about is actually evolutionary success
the fact that there's lots of certain
kind of creatures is not in any way a
reflection of their experience of life
so for example domesticated cattle are
hugely populous in the world right now
and live absolutely horror horrible
horrible lives even though from an
evolutionary point they're one of them
the most successful creatures in the
world are we kind of at that point
ourselves that we've enslaved ourselves
in this way well possibly yeah I mean
I've also read that book and his
subsequent book he has this wonderful
chapter on the Agricultural Revolution
which is meant to be the great leap of
humanity when we stopped you know
messing around in forests
hunter-gathering and and started you
know agricultural communities that's you
know freed up some people to be poets
and comedians and manufacturers and all
of that and you know off society went he
has this really counterintuitive sort of
explanation of this a he says you know
people's diets completely collapsed and
in fact apparently life expectancy
collapsed at that time because people
were wandering around the forest and
they were eating a great variety
of stuff and then they became kind of
mono diet Aries people whatever the
whatever the word is they were just
eating one thing they were also doing
back breaking work
but even more interesting Li he said
they'd become they'd become slaves to
wheat because the wheat Jean passed from
being quite sort of narrowly confined
and went all over the world so humans
from roaming around happy as Larry
suddenly started working in this
back-breaking toil for wheat and so
there we were
you know praising ourselves increasing
our numbers so that we could work harder
for wheat we're all we know so you know
we think we've taken over maybe wheats
taken over it's it's absolutely
fascinating this whole conversation and
just coming back to we've talked a
little bit about how we might measure
well-being measure growth measure GDP or
whatever it is but what is the cost of
what we're doing now because one of the
things you talk about in the book and in
other places that I've seen you speak as
well is the fact that for example if
when we measured GDP as basically
something gets sold or not sold if say
you have children right and you don't
pay someone else to raise them you raise
them yourself yes that is not a
contribution to GDP even though
statistic lives very likely to be better
for your children than having them
brought up by a stranger yes breast milk
is a good example tells you that well so
breast milk contributes zero to GDP but
you know any dietitian nutrition will
tell you that this is the best thing you
know that a mother can do for her child
and yet you know in the developing world
you know you might have ad campaigns and
people trying to encourage people to go
back to work contribute to the economy
you know and you can buy powder you know
maybe make with you know and you can
dilute it with water you know of
questionable origin or you know good
good better and different and and you
know health of children the next
generations will suffer but your
contribution to the economy has gone up
well did you not even say that you can
reduce child mortality by like 20
percent it's by breastfeeding or
something along there there are some
staggering
numbers yes and it's particularly strong
in the developing world and you can see
if you're a politician and someone comes
to you and says you know we could have a
breast feeding campaign that'll cost X
or I can build a great big Factory down
the road we can employ all these people
they'll pay tax you know you might be
able to take a bit of a backhander know
what sounds good to you so the fact that
we kind of monetize bits of the economy
and call that the economy and the other
bits of the economy every bit as real
and are not monetized and not counted
sets up these kind of weird invisible
incentives I think and that by
definition we may not be aware of are
not aware of but it can kind of skew the
direction that society is going and not
always for the better and what are the
other example sorry France and where are
the examples of how this way of
measuring growth effects us and the
notion could be another good one so you
know if your goal is to maximize output
then not only do we measure pollution as
a kind of byproducts of whatever it is
we're making so if you take China you
know it's been growing at 10% a year for
years and a lot of that growth is
absolutely real it's been transformative
I'm not knocking growth in especially in
poor countries and but part of that
growth has been just awful you know
fouling up the air fouling up the rivers
destroying biodiversity some of which
will be irreversible but if we try to
reverse it clean up the air clean up the
rivers that will also contribute to GDP
so you double count stuff that is you
know bad for us and yet m2 our standard
gauge of economics standard gauge of
what an economy is you know we don't
differentiate as long as it's bought
sold the bought and sold it's good no
matter what it is it could be armaments
so the more arms you produce the more
wars that look that go on the more
cities you this story and have to
rebuild you know all of that is good for
the flow of income and you've destroyed
wealth in the process and then you but
not to mention lives but it's good for
the economy this must be something wrong
with the measure that you know that puts
that on a pedestal and that finds it
harder to look at these you know what
what economists call externalities or
side-effects of our growth
[Music]
we're gonna be moving on a little bit
now um so you were taught you see your
Africa correspondent I mean that is it
that's a huge amount of land to be a
quarry so I mean how does that work
could you show you everywhere from
Algeria right the way through to
Zimbabwe well actually I don't cover in
North Africa so I come out so I'm this
sub-saharan so it's a mere fifty
countries so you know I can breathe a
sigh of relief look yes it's very it's a
very complicated challenging job because
there are 50 countries with different
histories with different languages and
different cultures and different
economies with different presidents with
different visa requirements and you know
and I suppose I'm expected to know about
if not all of them then an awful lot of
them and to you know report news and
trends and business opportunities and
cultural changes and you know exciting
technological developments and just you
know and human rights abuses and
politics and economics and you know and
I tend to write I sleep on aircraft you
fly down to blindness Africa look I'm
based in London and part of me thinks I
should be based somewhere in Africa but
of course Africa is I mean the bit of
Africa I cover is 50 countries so if
you're in South Africa then by
definition you're not in Nigeria or
you're not in Malawi or you're not in
Kenya and to some extent they make sense
to cover it from here and to keep flying
down and then fly back up and and Lynx
partly as a sort of hangover of
colonialism links between African
countries are not that good so it can be
extraordinarily expensive costly
cumbersome to move between countries
that on a map looks side-by-side it can
be easier bizarrely to fly back up to
London and then down again really so
it's easier to fly from from a country
to go to vile London to a cat it can be
I mean this is this is now being eroded
thank God
slightly but you know especially if you
have a country that was colonized by the
French and the country that comrades by
the British and they're next door to
each other yeah I mean you know it
started off with telephone system so you
used to route the telephone call through
the capital of one colonial power to the
capital or the other
your power and back down to the other
colonized power and those kind of
patterns become kind of structures and
this is I mean and it's important
because you know this is very damaging
to the way economies cultures all sorts
of things work because they're they
always tend to be in reference to the
former colonial power and the colonial
power a were hilux positive and B
weren't around for that long they came
they grabbed they smash they left and
and you know and now countries countries
that weren't really countries in the
current form have to now get on with
being nation-states and you know you
know maximizing potential for their own
populations and it's a nice tricky so
it's tricky for them and it's very
tricky for me to to grapple with all
this but it's that's why it's a
fascinating wonderful job Wow so I'm
what country do you do most of your
reporting is Erb ones that you
particularly pay attention to is yeah
there are some so South Africa has been
a big deal for us recently I mean it's
the biggest or second-biggest economy it
changes depending on exchange rate
fluctuations Nigeria is the other very
big one and so South Africa and you know
it's a big kind of motor of the African
economy there's a lot of investment goes
into South Africa there's obviously lot
of mining but I think even more
important than all of those really I
mean so much was kind of you know the
world's attention used to be on South
Africa during the whole and C apartheid
stuff you know then you had the fall of
the white government you had you know
the rise of the ANC Nelson Mandela
there was great sort of hope and we know
the drama and the and the figures
involved and kind of watching South
Africa now sometimes watching it go
wrong sometimes sometimes watching it go
right you know he's just sort of
fascinating in its own in its own right
so you know Cyril Ramaphosa who was a
union leader who was Mandela's choice to
take over as president but was ousted in
the ANC became a very very wealthy
businessman then became vice president
under Jacob Zuma Jacob Zuma dragging the
country down into kind of towards
catastrophe I would say and then Rama
poses strikes late last year becomes the
president and I got an hour with him
last week when I had it so we
interviewed him
and that is an amazing arc there's an
amazing history there there's an awful
lot to talk about em and you can bring
you know the drama of a country like
South Africa alive through an interview
like that and and so South Africa
there's a very long answer to a short
question South Africa has been one but
by no means all I mean I've spent quite
a lot of time in Nigeria which is also
really interesting I've sort of picked
on little countries for some reason so I
spent a bit of time in Liberia she's
somewhere I knew nothing about
beforehand but which I've become kind of
you know interested in I spend a fair
bit of time in Kenya DRC the Democratic
Republic of Congo I write a fair bit
about you know there's a quite a lot of
places Mozambique for some other reason
I found myself going to a few times and
what are the challenges do you think
some of those countries face because
I'll be honest with you I don't think in
in the UK we know we know a lot about
them if you wants the average person I
know maybe not its wife or Londoner
Nigeria Ghana
yes Africa yeah I think everyone's like
Barry average thing is with Africa like
Francis is saying I don't think really
knows anything I think the way we think
of Africa we talk about because very
much like Donald Trump talks about
Europe is like one homogenous sure
absolutely which obviously really annoys
you know anyone yeah you know Africa you
know Africa is a country meaning Africa
is not a country yeah is a kind of a
meme so I'm very careful you know I mean
occasionally one can talk about Africa
as a unit and it makes sense just like
you might talk about Europe or the
Americas or Asia
you know from Bangladesh to Japan it
might make sense to talk about those
countries you know as a unit but
generally it makes much more sense to
talk about individual countries or
individual regions I mean look the first
big challenge that African countries
have is that then that they're not self
defined countries and you know they
would they were drawn on a map in Berlin
by
guys with mustaches many of them had
never been to the continent that they
were carving up among the colonial
powers and you know that has created an
enormous damage you know you have people
who speak the same language on different
sides of borders you know you have
people who have nothing really in common
who are you know thrown into the same
country and and they have to build a
sense of nation-state a sense of purpose
you know a sense a project which you
know what I saw in Asia for example in
China in Japan in Korea had been you
know sort of 2000 3000 4000 5000 year
old cultures and while you know African
cultures are in a sense the oldest of
the lot but in their modern formation in
the state of Nigeria or the state of
Kenya their modern creations and and
that that's the that's the first problem
and is that why you see they're thick
and religious conflicts all over the
continent though that we probably have
heard of I think we also kind of
exaggerate I mean for a start there's
very there have been very few wars
between African countries I mean you
know you might you know that maybe our
view but I would say it's a prejudiced
view if you want to if you want war
killing mayhem looks at Europe that's
where we've had more of it than anywhere
else these borders artificially drawn
they haven't been many wars between
African states but within there's been
yes like an idea of religious tension
absolutely Rwanda you know was what
there was a genocide yeah I mean you
know there's no no two ways about that
and you know you you can trace that back
to the Belgians kind of trying to
distinguish between you know in a very
kind of racist way trying to say you are
Hutu you are Tutsis and there is a
strong argument that people didn't
really think in that way beforehand so
some of this may be actually you know
the colonial powers have kind of
fermented this but yeah look I mean
different peoples with different
languages different beliefs you know
unless they can find a way of getting
one with each other sometimes don't get
on with each other we've seen that
throughout history and you know and that
that's true in in many African countries
but I would challenge the notion that
and you know that there's more violence
more turmoil
more inter-ethnic rivalry I mean look at
Britain yeah you know you know we've
been you know a country sort of
self-determined country for hundreds and
hundreds of years we're still arguing
about the Scots the Welsh the English
was still arguing about immigration
we're still arguing about whether we're
part of Europe or not and you know but
if I called that you know tribal England
tribal Britain you know right up there
with a new republic all I'm saying this
one has to be one has to be careful and
you shouldn't look through the you know
the it's it's easy to fall into sort of
stereotypical tsunami what is happening
on the continent right now what should
we think about what should we know about
what is it the people in the West who
don't know anything about Africa you
know think about it okay well there are
a few things and then no by no means all
good but some of them are good so I
would say Africa is Africa there go pass
of Africa are becoming more democratic
and I've been actually really sort of
impressed by people on the streets sort
of idealism about what democracy means
this is a real contrast with you know
the West where you know younger people
lots of surveys show are kind of more
and more disenchanted with democracy
yeah and in the United States there are
surveys that show you know should the
military takeover you know yeah I don't
know the numbers but 50 years ago it
would have been nobody and it's creeping
up much more do you think one strong man
but you could solve this country answer
you know so it's gone like this so what
you're seeing is a disenchantment with
democracy in you know large sways of the
West and in Africa is actually going the
other way you get people doing it
suddenly moving things you know
campaigning lining up walking to polling
booths voting once voting twice voting
three times taking pictures on their
mobile phones of ballot sheets and
uploading them having a whole kind of
civil society thing to make sure that
the result of the election is fair and
so many people that I've heard whether
in Ghana or Nigeria or Kenya
or Liberia saying we don't mind who wins
but we want the election to be fair and
we want the person who loses to step
down go with grace and and this doesn't
always happen so in the Democratic
Republic of Congo you've got Joseph
Kabila who's refusing to go but it's
happening all over the place so there
was just an election in Sierra Leone
which I don't think made headline news
here but but you know but it made a
little bit of news yeah an election in
Liberia which actually did kind of
briefly make headline news
so you'd had a woman who'd been in power
Ellen Johnson Sirleaf actually the first
elected female leader in Africa who had
been in for two terms who her time was
up her party lost the election she
stepped down her party conceded defeat
and that is becoming much much more than
norm so I was in Gambia at the beginning
of 2000 I'm just so I think the
beginning of 2017 and when they've just
been an election and there was a mad
kind of dictator called yaha jammy who
said he was going to be in power I think
it's for a billion years because he's
now out of power so sometimes done the
calculation how many years he's missed
it yeah misses his target by he lost the
election he originally said he would go
then he backtracks and said I'm not
going to go then the regional powers
sort of said you know you will be going
thank you very much and I was there
during all of this and they were
pressuring him they were even kind of
threatening Pat to invade and then he
went and there was a new guy dama Barrow
who had actually had worked in Britain I
think he'd been at one point a security
guard at Argos but he's also been a
property developer wherever you I'd like
you can always always make it so you ask
me what so one thing I would say is that
democracy is kind of in a weird sort of
way alive and kicking in parts of Africa
in a way that it's not in parts of the
West so it's fascinating to me as a
Russian because in Russia we still
haven't had this right we've never had
that transitional power without any
interference the rush
never happen and what you're saying is
Africa increasingly is having that yes
and it's patchy it can go two steps back
you know whatever whatever the phrase is
but but it but there is something
definitely happening and it's
interesting and moving and positive
other than that's incredible and that's
really heartwarming um well I come from
a lot in America back home where my
mother is and politics there it's just
riddled with corruption and obviously
the stereotype and again it's a
stereotype of African politics is a
corruption corruption is essentially
pretty much destroyed Venezuela and it's
and its economy yeah how much of a
challenge is Africa faced with its
corruption and politics yeah huge look
you know democracy is kind of war by
other means and and the way that these
countries have been kind of formed and
you know people's loyalties might not be
to the state of Kenya it might be to the
Kikuyu and we kind of think that kaku's
a tribe but that's a really silly way of
looking at it it better to think of it
as like the English or something you
know these are cultures with their own
language it you know with their own
belief system with their own kind of
cultural traits and and sort of sense of
identity and unity and so if you're in
power and your loyalty may be more to
you know the Kikuyu then to this is kind
of artificial nation and called Kenya
and and that can breed corruption I mean
also what if you don't have you know
institutions I mean we've seen in the
West how fragile institutions can be you
know you get a president comes up says I
don't believe in the FBI they make up
stuff I don't believe in fate New York
Times you know I don't believe in the
court system and you know even when
we've had some hundreds and hundreds of
years of this our kind of belief system
can be quite shaky if you've never
really had that and there was no real
intention by the colonial powers
certainly Britain to build these things
you know they left the countries with
you know handfuls of graduates you know
they didn't really leave much behind in
terms of you know functioning
institutions so to build those up from
scratch and those are the things that
are checks and balances
otherwise who comes to power people come
to power that wants to enrich themselves
and not always I should say but you know
but depressingly often so what you need
is you need the growth of civil society
which I definitely am seeing you know
you need institutions to put their foot
down to draw lines which used to seep
sporadically so when I was in Kenya and
there was an election and there was a
claim that the election hadn't been
entirely fair the Supreme Court annulled
the election it was kind of a big shock
and lo and behold people agreed and
peacefully went back to the polls they
had another election it was actually
kind of the same results but that's but
but you know democracy at work isn't it
that's democracy at work I mean you know
that happen in America you'd say that's
amazing the functioning of democracy
despite all the problems well this
happened in Kenya yeah so you know
absolutely you know if people come to
power and they steal lots of money and
they enrich their own class and they
send their money offshore that is awful
terrible you know you could say that's
what's happened in in oil-rich countries
like Nigeria and Angola you know to a
depressing degree and but that is
certainly not the whole story and the
other thing we should remember of course
is that it takes two to tango it takes
two to be corrupt and on the other side
of the table are often our own Western
companies who want to extract minerals
or oil or whatever and you know if
someone's taking a bribe you can be sure
that someone's paying a bribe to make
sense and one of the other things
probably final thing that would talk
about on Africa
you mentioned the population growth
there and one of the things you've
talked about now is that now about 1
billion of the world's 7 billion people
live in Africa and within I think by the
end of the century said it would be 4
out of 12 billion so 4 out of 11 for our
11:11 so more than so we go from 7th to
more than 1/3 that's right and tell us
about that ok so there's a guy called
Hans Rosling who died that's the guy I
was talking about hands Rosling who I
think's a genius I really love Hans
Rosling he has this easy way of
remembering the world's population which
is he says the pincode of
world is 1 1 1 4 so that means there's 1
billion people these are approximate
numbers 1 billion people live in the
Americas 1 billion live in Europe 1
billion live in Africa and 4 billion
live in Asia we tend to think of the
world's population is exploding but this
is not true because if you fast forward
to 2050 the pincode of the world becomes
1 1 to 5
ie 1 billion in a map in the Americas
because the Americas has basically
stopped growing 1 billion in Europe
because Europe has basically stopped
growing another billion in Asia I
another what is that 25% and because hey
Asia is really slowing down and then it
will sort of stop but Africa keeps
growing so it goes to 2 billion and then
it made double again by the end of the
century to 4 billion so he said I think
jokingly that you know his his tip for
his investment tip is real estate in
Somalia because he said because because
he says that the whole kind of focus of
the global economy will tilt hmm from
the Pacific and the Atlantic to the
Indian Ocean because then you will have
5 billion people in Africa and sorry 4
billion in Africa and 5 billion in Asia
centered around the Indian Ocean and
that that will become the kind of the
whole locus of world trade and business
and you know this is futurology so you
can't take it too seriously and and I
certainly don't advise buying beachfront
territory in Mogadishu right yet but you
never know and the locus of the world is
shifting there and I think that's
something that that is important in in
very interesting ways
possibly in in frightening ways if you
know if those people don't have jobs if
their economies aren't functioning then
that's going to lead to you know huge
amounts of turmoil which will not be
confined to Africa and if they do have
jobs and they and they are in
functioning economies then you know what
what we have tended to see as the kind
of the problem continent could become a
locus of sort of you know opportunity
and and
you know growth start saving up for
property market this year twenty years
from now billing thank you very much for
coming on your on Twitter at two David
filling filling and the book is called
the growth delusion it is indeed fun and
just before we go Constantine what's
your Twitter handle ad Constance and
kiss and I still have the Russian BOTS
following me so join them Frances foster
I'm failing human give me a follow on
that and yeah I really enjoyed it thank
you very much thank you follow us at
trigger pod on all the social media
subscribe to the YouTube channel very
important and we'll see in the next
episode thank you very much and also
before we go just make sure to leave a
rating five stars please and tell us
what you think and even better if you
really enjoy it tell a friend thank you
[Music]